it's amazing
in addition in addition to the ps4
console experience the full Resident
Evil 7 will be playable from beginning
to end with PlayStation VR when it
releases on January 24th 2016 is a
seminal moment in virtual reality the
time has finally come for everyone to
enjoy VR in their own homes and at
PlayStation we have a combination of the
necessary processing and graphics power
already built inside 40 million PS fours
that have been sold worldwide
we thank you
we have the display technology which can
realize these images at a high fidelity
we have the production expertise to
create a headset that it's designed for
the gamer and because PlayStation 4 is a
fixed platform developers can fine-tune
their games for the system to deliver
the same transformative experience for
all PlayStation VR owners I'm happy to
announce here that on October 13th
PlayStation VR will make its debut in
the United States
currently more than 50 games will be
available from launch until the end of
this year that includes some of the
biggest franchises along with brand-new
titles that will be born on psvr
we invite those here tonight after the
experience and after this experience to
come with us
next door to the arena post reception
we'll be able to have some psvr das set
up so you can all have a go now I'd like
to showcase a few PlayStation VR titles
starting with PlayStation exclusives
developed by our own worldwide studios
please my god place is incredible
what's your suit on those rugs you don't
know what kind of pathogens might exist
here we can't afford a breach
come on we have to keep moving I bet
this place isn't even on the star charts
analyzing surroundings
unknown environment unknown atmosphere
unknown location
wait what the hell is that
pilgrim can you read me this is dr.
Tyson and dr. moon come back